Hmm, I’d say mine is pretty short, but thick.
Sometimes textured...
Talkin about the HAIR, people.
Hey there, hairy humans, Trace here for DNews.
There are so many different types of hair
– wavy, straight, fine, thin, thick, curly,
bushy, wiry…
Some people’s hair is easy to comb, while
others are constantly battling a tangled mess.
But is there really an advantage to having
a certain type of hair?
We’ve talked a bit about why we have hair
at all in another DNews video, but needless
to say.
We have it.
Fur and hair is the same thing.
All mammals have hair, including us.
Hair is composed of keratin, a fibrous, resilient
protein that gives hair its strength.
The keratin protein is made up of long chains
of amino acids bonded together, the most abundant
of which is “cysteine,” which is able
to form strong bonds with itself, called disulfide
bonds.
That’s important because where these bonds
accumulate on the hair shaft influences the
shape of the hair!
For example, in curly hair, the protein builds
up more on one side of the hair, causing it
to curve, whereas in straight hair, it’s
distributed more evenly throughout.
There’s even a condition called “uncombable
hair syndrome” involving a gene mutation
that doesn’t allow keratin to bond to the
hair shaft correctly causing extremely dry,
frizzy hair and endless tangles.
But, keratin isn’t the only thing that changes
hair type, the shape of the hair follicles
--- the structures in your skin that grow
your hair -- influence its shape and thickness.
Larger follicles produce thicker strands of
hair, smaller follicles thinner strands…
makes sense.
But, if the follicles are say, oval-shaped,
or asymmetrical, then the hair that comes
out of them won’t be perfectly round; instead
it bends to one side, producing curls.
Think about it like gift-wrapping ribbon---when
you run scissors along one side, it’ll curl.
It’s a similar principle with an asymmetrical
follicle – one side is flat, the other curved,
resulting in ringlets.
Frizz and texture are often associated with
curly hair because natural oils secreted by
your scalp can’t move down the hair as easily.
Those oils trap moisture in the hair -- which
is why humidity makes curly hair even more
frizzy!
But there’s definitely one advantage of
having curly hair – and it’s not what
you think.
Curly hair actually tangles LESS than straight
hair.
Yep!
A study published in the American Journal
of Physics found that the angle at which straight
hairs bump into each other is most likely
to cause tangling.
See, the outside of your hair -- called the
cuticle -- consists of a series of overlapping
keratin cells, like shingles on a roof.
If the hairs meet at a sharp angle, the cuticles
hook onto each other.
Although straight hairs meet less often than
curly hairs overall, when they do, they tend
to meet at steeper angles and thus are more
likely to hook and tangle than curly hairs.
We all have different hair, but there’s
not a hard evolutionary reason why.
Though there are a bunch of hypotheses as
to how we got it.
Like one 2013 study in the journal Cell which
found a specific gene mutation that causes
thicker hair.
It emerged 30,000 years ago in central China,
later spreading to Africa and Europe.
That same gene mutation also had other effects,
such as increasing the density of sweat glands.
The researchers believe that high humidity
in East Asia at the time may have given people
with the mutation an advantage because they
could sweat more efficiently, and perhaps
thicker hair simply propagated as a side effect
of the gene.
Another study in the American Journal of Human
Genetics identified two genes which cause
curly hair in European descendents, but even
they say the exact point when curly hair evolved
is unknown.
More research is needed to see what other
factors could have been involved.
But whether you’ve got stick straight strands
or corkscrew curls, hair is completely individual
– so embrace what nature gave you!
And remember: it’s the size… (of the follicle)
that matters…
I hated my hair for a long time until I figured
out how to take care of it.
It was a process, but now, I love it!
Or, what’s left of it…
Want to know more about hair?
Here are five weird uses for it...besides
just keeping your head warm.
Also, check out this video from our friends
at Seeker Stories about how professional actors
are teaching medical students how to interact
with patients.
Got any hair tips?
Tell us in the comments, please subscribe
for more DNews and thanks for watching.